we're going to talk about what's been
dominating the news over the last number
of days and that is the carl rittenhouse
verdict
and it's a tough subject anytime i think
about it it just makes me
sad and disheartened for
where we are as a country
i thought that the verdict was
uh
legally appropriate but a very very
tough and uh negative message i feel
like we need a trigger warning if we're
going to talk about kyle written house
because we've been silent
avoiding twitter on this
well twitter is the wrong medium correct
my mind you know what i mean it's like
you put something out and then you have
to go uh deeper into it so first let me
say that the entire thing just makes me
very very sad i think that is the
appropriate emotion where
this
young man kid i mean he was technically
a kid at the time 17
goes to the site of
a protest with an automatic weapon
ends up
killing two people and wounding another
and then is acquitted
and i have a tough set of emotions on it
because i think that
what we see here is someone who did
something that in my mind was
the opposite of praiseworthy was immoral
was dangerous it ended up taking
people's lives but i understand the
verdict because according to the letter
of the law you can see why
they can argue that he was acting in
self-defense and that the state did not
meet its burden of proof
and for the folks around the country who
are saying look this verdict doesn't
send a positive message i would happen
to agree with that like i think that uh
somehow stamping that this kind of
dangerous
uh
careless reckless kind of behavior
uh that did result in people's deaths is
legal i think is a very very
uh
negative message uh to be sent out there
but i understand why
he was acquitted because
i think that the self-defense
rationale
was
borne out
by various pieces of evidence
people on both sides are very very very
have been very very angry about this
they're very very emotional about this
do you think
to me my opinion is that this
like a
poster child for media inflammation of
certain stories do you think the media
is a lot to blame with how
how we're literally so polarized on on
this trial oh yeah i mean the media
unfortunately is now
trying to pit everything in terms of
this
civil war which in my opinion is more
and more likely in part because of the
media there's a bit of a self-fulfilling
prophecy going on and certainly the
lionization of kyle rittenhouse uh in
certain quarters of the
right right leaning or
um you know fox news universe i
completely disagree with i mean like
presenting kyle rittenhouse as
uh a hero strikes me as very very
irresponsible
but you know on the other side i think
that they're presenting kyle rittenhouse
as
uh also some kind of racially motivated
white supremacist type
which uh you know i i don't think
is
necessarily borne out also by the fact
or should be the focus i mean the focus
should be that these two people lost
their lives a person was wounded uh and
for
kyle rittenhouse especially because in
this case you know when you look at it
and say well it shows that you know
white man can do no wrong um in the
united states of america i mean his
victims were white so you know that
doesn't necessarily fit the prevailing
type of narrative
though what it says to me really is that
our gun laws are messed up which i think
a lot of people would agree with but
according to the laws as they're
currently written i understand the
verdict
these four things can all be true at the
same time and if you live on twitter
none of them only one can be true or so
um these are the four one national media
did not cover
this case accurately particularly in the
year or so
leading up to the trial
that's number one number two that this
is objectively a tragedy that a 17 year
old with an automatic rifle feeling that
he
not only needs to defend his city or be
in that um that environment but that
maybe that he's entitled to do that that
he should be right um i think that's a
tragedy um the third one is that the
evidence of self-defense was
pretty to i would say very strong
actually when you look at the facts of
the case um
and then
castro tweeted this and i thought was
interesting is that if cal britton house
was black
we're probably having a different
conversation and there's a probably a
significantly higher chance he's in jail
um
i mean there's a higher chance that he
would have been shot on the scene if
he'd been like you know
like there is an issue where he was
walking past law enforcement with his
hands up and they were supporting him
yeah yeah so encouraging him so so that
those things are real um but
no
i don't think that it's appropriate to
want a verdict uh to to
be in keeping with like a particular
um
message i mean it is a person it's a
court of law if the person's
uh to be acquitted on the basis of the
law i mean you have to accept that in my
view
um so it's a very tough situation it
makes me sad it makes me sad for the
families of the
people who lost their lives uh it makes
me sad that our country
um is trying to make
a cause out of what in my view is
something that a very very
you know irresponsible immature 17 year
old did like lionizing that that kid is
a hero strikes me as irresponsible on
itself
no one of the the struggles that i have
very often
is that
you see something happen particularly in
this age of social media and then you
magnify it and you can look at this
incident say oh
there's like a race war or civil war and
and that's a narrative that the media
does love and love to fuel and i i try
and remove myself at least a couple
steps and say wait like is this like an
army of
people all organized or is this just one
in this case you know 17 year old with
terrible ideas
and
you know and then the the reverse
happens in waukesha wisconsin and you
can say look is this all
people of color or black people like of
course not like we we can't be seeing
things through these collectivized
racialized lenses or else anytime
someone does something it's like oh all
people of that background
will think a certain way will act a
certain way as soon as you start to
generalize
to that degree then we're lost in my
opinion like i try and look at something
and say okay this human being made these
terrible decisions
and our systems do have issues for sure
and i think there's a way that we can
make progress on them without succumbing
to some of like the baser
narratives but this thing just has made
me very sad and i do
very very much dislike the message that
somehow it's appropriate to take the law
into your own hands leave the house with
a weapon like that right like those
things are very negative in my view i
was talking to carly about this and she
said there's like the macro argument and
the micro argument so on this macro like
macro on a justice level and the macro
justice level
there's a lot of people on the left
there's like well white people been in
power for a long time and they deserve
this and on a macro maybe that is if
you're trying to balance a scale maybe
that's a true statement but on the micro
level if you look at kyle as a human in
the actual cases and that um
you know if i was watching from the
outside i was looking like i was i felt
i thought we all were
under the impression that he was
from outside of wisconsin brought his
ak-47 that he got illegally
and
was shooting down mowing down black
lives matter protesters and then he's a
white supremacist and that was like the
recurring narrative even on the right
and they were saying you know the
wright's early narrative was
this is the fault of bad government and
not the fault of the kid and they were
even defending even they weren't even
you know they're kind of giving that
side of the argument to the democrats
but when you look at the facts is that
he was actually from kenosha like he
lived there his dad lived there he had a
job there
the gun was legal in the state of
wisconsin
um
and the people he shot were not black
lives matter protesters they were
actually convicted
criminals who are who are white and not
that that matters when you talk about
human life but it's just a different
narrative that's been framed so there's
macro
and micro and i think twitter doesn't
know there's no nuance for that a lot of
people don't want that nuance they
picked a team and they're they're either
happy or upset about this and it's a
shame i think it's a tragic yeah if
you're on team humanity or or team usa
it's just sad it's like uh you know like
the thing and it does in my view send a
message you do not want to send which is
that vigilantism
uh is
somehow appropriate uh or that this
person's actions were somehow
uh
not just legal but moral or praiseworthy
yeah you know like like though
i happen to think that
he should not have been there certainly
with a firearm and the rest of it and
that these people's lives should not
have been lost in this way the fact that
you can get these types of weapons uh
yeah that's that's really good and open
carry that problem and and in wisconsin
it's totally illegal to walk so but i
wanted to make sure we we haven't talked
about it at all well before frankly the
trial was going on and then what do you
need to talk about and then the verdict
comes out and then it's just like a
hypercharged like twitter atmosphere and
then you're like well you know it's like
i would have to go on for
um
some length uh to try and express
something that isn't and and part of it
too is like i always try and be helpful
or productive and so if you're like hey
i'm just going to
you know say something to say it you
know it didn't seem like the right
approach but clearly you know we we see
this and
um
at least on my side like i just felt
very sad about it every every
uh
you know time i've
been reflecting on it the last number of
days
[Music]
you